we have our first unfiltered look this
morning inside a facility for separated
immigrant children CBS News obtained
cell phone video from inside the Cayuga
centers in New York the clip shows
children huddled in what looked like
classrooms including one crying girl who
couldn't talk to her mother
vladimir duthiers of our streaming
network CBS and shows how the children
are coping after weeks of separation
from their families flat good morning
good morning as you know the government
will not let cameras into these shelters
Gail you know that officials release
images that they only want you to see
these videos were provided to us by
attorney Michael avenatti a trump
administration critic they were
apparently shot by an employee who was
troubled by family separations and
recently quit when we first see Leo he's
all smiles but that smile disappears
when he's asked if he's sad about being
away from his mother attorney Michael
avenatti represents Leo's mother lourdes
he says the two were separated 48 hours
after arriving at the Texas border May
10 was for the better part of three
weeks and she was distraught over it
what is Leo's mother status now she's
been deported back to Guatemala Leo was
sent to the Cayuga centers in New York
he's one of 243 separated children there
according to Mayor Bill DeBlasio Cayuga
cares for the children during the day at
night they go home to foster families
Jessica
[Music]
this young girl named Jessica said she
arrived at the u.s. with her ten year
old brother
she was crying because she wanted to
speak to her mother
[Music]
employees were heard complaining there
were not enough phones for the children
to talk to their parents
hanadi says the former employee wanted
the video released because she was very
bothered by the influx of children into
the center
we asked avenatti why he's getting
involved in a stress in my view the most
important thing above all else is these
children need to be reunited with their
parents
and it needs to happen now some would
say perhaps that you've got a bone to
pick with president Trump and this is
just another way for you to be sort of
thorn in his side how do you respond to
that no I have a problem with people
that use children four pawns whether
that be here in New York or in
California or Texas or anywhere else in
this country the Cayuga centers and the
Department of Health and Human Services
did not respond to our request for a
comment
Abin adi says he represents more than 60
families who have been separated from
more than 70 children he says about 80
percent of his clients have had no
contact with their children and they
don't even know where they are
something tells me he will see this
through do you know anything about the
little boy with the mom who's already
gone back to Guatemala we can I asked
him about that and he doesn't know
because the government is not rating
information with him thank you thank you
glad